Why doesn't this look right?
UNRESOLVED GESTALT!!!!!
Hey there intelligent designers, I'm Trace,
this is DNews.
Your brain evolved to look at the natural
world, and you might think, what a mess!
There's dirt and leaves and plants and stuff
scattered EVERYWHERE!
But that's not really true.
When you look at a tree you don't see a branch,
and a leaf, and trunk -- you see a tree.
But… why?
In 1912, in Germany, three psychologists named
Max Wertheimer, Wolfgang Köhler and Kurt
Koffka started the Gestalt Psychology movement.
Gestalt means -- "placed," or "put together"
with the base idea being: "the whole of anything
is greater than its parts."
A great example of Gestalt psychology in action
is watching a movie.
It's really a collection of still images,
but together, the still frames become so much
more.
Another example is this… you see it as lights
moving around the marquee, but if you think
about it, you know that's not what is really
happening.
If you were to look at one lightbulb, it simply
turns on, then off for a time, then on again.
Our brains create the movement, and story.
That's not actually the reality.
There are numerous Gestalt principles: Similarity,
Continuity, Prägnanz (simplicity), Symmetry,
Closure, and Common Fate… just to name a
few.
The law of Proximity or grouping: says our
brain groups things that are near each other,
together.
Unless of course, they're different, in which
case the law of Similarity: says we'll group
similar things first.
We'll also assume because of the law of continuity
-- that the smoothest curve is the "correct"
path to follow7.
Though, if that curve intersects another,
we'll see the overall group in it's simplest
form -- a.k.a. is Pragnanz.
And of course, we prefer symmetry, we don't
see these as 1 2 2 1, but rather 2 2 2 -- our
brain turns them into sets.
Of course, you don't have to see anything
to perceive something.
The principle of closure describes how your
brain does it for you…
like here in the "Implied Triangle" -- there's
no triangle there, but you see one.
Then if this group moves, we assume they move
as one -- because of the principle of common
fate.
All these things are ways our brain organizes
visual information.
Over last century, psychologists and designers
have been studying how our brain perceives
the world around us, and the stories it tells
our conscious mind.
That's important because how we see the world
affects decision-making, bias, causal reasoning,
memory formation… you name it.
Some would argue, perception is far more powerful
than reality.
In fact, according a fascinating study in
the Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences, these design principles are what
allow us to read.
When humans look at words, we see them as
shapes.
Grouping them, recognizing the shapes, and
following along with the lines on a page,
or around in a circle along the curves.
Think kinetic typography.
You can follow what I'm saying, not because
you're reading it, but because of design understanding,
psychology, and neural pattern recognition.
When you're reading scrambled text, you're
still getting their shape, and using a bunch
of brain regions to process visual cues.
Brains are awesome.
Understanding how our brains organize visual
information is super important, because decoding
all that information takes EFFORT.
It burns ENERGY.
Maybe this is why we like well-designed spaces,
because it takes less cognitive resources
to understand them, or to accomplish tasks
while in them, but what do you think?